un an après l'apparition d'une épidémie
de chikungunya à la réunion on en sait
un peu plus sur ce fameux virus du
moustique premier constat malgré les
opérations de démoustication il est
toujours présent dans l'île et second
constat il s'étend dans l'océan indien
et selon certains spécialistes il
pourrait même gagner un jour les
capitales européennes envoyés spéciaux
nicolas chateauneuf mathias second c'est
un combat qu'il faut sans cesse
recommencé à la réunion les combinaisons
les masques et c'est drôle d'engin font
désormais partie du quotidien
alors là on va procéder à une
démoustification adultes sur un terrain
où est-ce qu'il ya deux cases abandonné
avec une végétation très dense
ils sont plus d'un millier sur l'île a
effectué ses gestes régulièrement un
jour ce sont les larves de moustiques
qu'il faut tuer l'autre jour ce sont les
insectes adultes qui transmettent à
l'homme le virus du chikungunya
en pulvérisant la végétation cette
végétation un petit peu denses comme ça
qu'ils qui généralement abrite le
moustique aedes albopictus parce qu'il
aime bien être protégés du soleil
l'autre combat se déroule dans les
laboratoires ou les recherches avancent
car le temps presse
en quelques mois le virus du chikungunya
a fait du chemin parties du kenya
il mute en septembre 2005 pour changer
de variété de moustique et envahir la
réunion puis il s'étend comores à
madagascar à l'île maurice et aux
seychelles
dernièrement il a touché l'inde avec un
million deux cent mille malades sa trace
a été signalée en malaisie en indonésie
et pour les spécialistes
rien ne l'empêchent de poursuivre sa
route dire qu'un jour le chikungunya
saura dans les grandes capitales du nord
de l'europe ou des états unis n'est pas
quelque chose de totalement impossible
il faudra pourtant attendre au moins
cinq ans pour fabriquer et valider un
vaccin
quant aux médicaments de récents cas à
madagascar traité à la nivaquine suscite
quelques espoirs
il semblerait que ça donnait des
résultats donc j'ai décidé d'en très
pragmatique de demandé au professeur
flahault d'envoyer ses équipes à
madagascar pour savoir exactement ce qui
s'est passé en attendant la réunion
devra continuer à se battre sur le
terrain car avec le retour des pluies
le moustique va pouvoir repasser à
l'attaqué